hello everyone my name is raymond
suhaninada i just i'm a recent
comat clinical chemistry fellow graduate
and
i
am still at uc san diego health and i'm
here to tell you a little bit about the
work i did during my fellowship which is
uh the title of this talk is covet 19
antibody testing and the pandemic
lessons learned
so
as many of you know now stars kobe 2 is
a virus and uh this is a
here we have an illustration of the
viral architecture of this virus
as you can see
when a virus
is
attempting to infect your cells
there is
a immune response
mediated by b cells
and antibodies are generated
as you can see there are two major
antigens on the
outside of the sars kobe 2 virus the
spike protein also known as the s
protein as well as the nuclear protein
also known as the n protein
and these are the two major
viral antigens
that serology assays
clinical serology assays have been
developed against
so
back in
early 2020 we at ucsd health were asked
can we
uh
validate
asar's kobe 2 serology assay uh mainly
because
uh as we all know
pcr based assays are great for acute
infection but what about past exposure
to the virus
so we were first tasked to determine if
they were indeed reliable and could be
used in the clinical setting
so we in fact did this we partnered with
a local company and we were fortunate
enough to get one of the first analyzers
to
perform a sars kobe 2
igg
antibody assay
this was a antibody assay directed
against the spike and nuclear captive
protein
and
as many of you know uh working the
clinical laboratories we are very
focused on the robustness of each assay
here we have a table
which
the header is the between one
cv the within run cv and the total cv
for the igg assay
on the
left column are the samples that we
tested
the positive qc and negative qc that
came with this kit as well as different
patient pools uh the patient pull high
patient pull low are
from
sars kobe 2 pcr positive patients
whereas the patient pulled negative are
from
these were
stored plasma
or serum samples from patients uh from
2018 frozen at minus uh
20 degrees celsius so
we consider these sars kobe 2 naive
patients
and as you can see
we had we saw a very good precision uh
between run within run in total for
for all of these
samples or patient pools
the only one where we had a large
variation in the cv was this patient
pool negative
uh this is at the time was because uh
we were essentially measuring noise and
as we can as you know when you're
measuring noise then uh the precision
goes uh
suffers greatly
so uh
while this isn't exactly what we wanted
to see it was expected since this assay
essentially would go down to zero would
report out zeros
we also at the time were very concerned
about cross reactivity to other types of
respiratory and
viruses
as well as
non-covid coronavirus
so here we have
a subset of different
samples from different patients and
infected with different respiratory
pathogens as well as different email
immunological diseases
um
hiv and a uh
anti-ds
essentially lupus here
um so
as you can see we didn't get any cross
reactivity
which is was very important
and giving us some confidence moving
forward with this assay
so
we also then
decided to take a look
to see if we could detect seroconversion
in sars kobe 2 confirmed patients
these are pcr positive patients and we
had
serial monitor we had longitudinal
samples and serially monitored them
through the course of disease
so in the left we actually also have i
didn't show you the precision data for
it but we also had an igm assay that
which looked at igm antibodies against
the sars kobe 2n and spike protein
and it had similar
precision as the igg assay
as you can see
when you look at these
patients over time
there is a point when
through the course of their disease that
they seroconvert
and the point where
this assay deems that to be a patient is
positive is one and this is a semi-log
scale
and
as you can see the median time to igm
with stereo conversion is five days
uh with an interquartile range of 2.75
to 9.
interestingly we saw
that
the igg sierra conversion was in fact
four days which is at the time was very
confusing we are uh educated that igm
uh
comes before igg during the humoral
response
it's
uh
was a little bit confusing at the time
however many other studies have reported
a similar
uh
effect that they they see
igm and igg almost come concurrently
which is a little different from other
um
the uh
serology the serology of different
diseases
so essentially we're seeing a serial
conversion on this assay about four days
one thing that we were heavily
questioned on is uh how do you
what about the prevalence and as we all
know prevalence does affect the positive
predictive value and negative predictive
value of all clinical tests
so we did some uh math essentially uh
based off of the sensitivity and
specificity we were observing in our
cohort
and this
uh
based on the sensitivity and specificity
of each assay in this case the igm assay
for starscore b2
uh we see we have we calculated the
positive predictive value of negative
predictive value at different prevalence
levels
and as you can see
for igm igg
as well as igm plus igg
around a one percent prevalence rate we
actually have really poor and positive
predictive value
and
we really focus on the one the the
single digit uh prevalence uh
levels
uh because uh
there were some discussions on whether
we should be screening the general
population
or whether or not we should only be
using it for
uh patients presenting with systems and
at the time at ucsd
we had a
estimated prevalence our pcr positivity
rate of about 4.3 percent as in 4.3
percent of the patients being tested
um
were
actually positive by
an rt pcr test
however
if we were going to go to the general
population we assumed that to be much
lower and we could already see if we're
looking at a one percent level our
positive predictive values are quite
poor
less than 70 and in fact for igg and i
in this panel is you know less than 50
about 50
so
one of the things that we try to
educate uh
on is how positive predictive value
works
so as you can see here the starscopy2
antibody test even assuming a great test
100 sensitivity 99 specificity
in a test population of one million with
a prevalence level of five percent
disease prevalence of five percent
uh there would only be fifty thousand
disease individuals in this population
uh
based on a specificity of 99 percent
you'd have a
10 000 10 000 individuals that were just
would just be false positives just based
on the math law
so putting in together and this is a the
formula that
is used to calculate positive predictive
value um which is the number of true
positives divided by the number of true
positives plus false positives
we would get a positive predictive value
of 83 percent roughly
and that's not bad but that's at a
prevalence level five percent
however
what about if
we took a different scenario
and we looked at the same population
with a prevalence level of a half
percent
uh in this population we have five
thousand disease only five thousand
disease individuals but the same number
of false positives
and what this does is it reduces our
positive predicted value to 33 percent
which is quite awful so it is just basic
math but it is
you know helpful to visualize it
especially in the context of screening
low prevalence populations
so
uh we were very proud to contribute
in this field
as we as you can see here
i'm showing you the website for the
journal of applied laboratory medicine
the highly cited collection where we
have
one of the most cited papers uh
uh or the most cited paper i'm not sure
i don't think there's actually a ranking
but uh still it is nice to have our work
net recognized and um
if you're interested here's the citation
and the doi
so
moving from the study we were interested
in how to improve the positive
predictive value moving forward as
especially as we begin to test low
prevalence populations
so
what we we were fortunate enough to be
uh to have sort of first dibs one of the
first dibs on the roche kovas and have
an architects uh as far as kobe 2
serology assays
um so for those of you that don't know
the roche kobas is an automated
chemistry analyzer uh where
uh
at ucsd health this is essentially our
workhorse
where we do most of our patient testing
we also at ucsd health have a nabit
architect where we do a lot of
immunosuppressants
and
anti-pro-bnp etc
that we had access to as well and both
of these vendors
had sars kobe 2 specific and antibody
tests
so
in this study we looked at
the individual performance and how
each of these assays
would
uh
the positive predictive values that you
would expect to see from each of these
assays in a clinical setting and again
much like we did previously
we saw really poor predict uh predictive
values
uh
in
using either acid any of these acids
either diazine roche or abbott
some are ranging from 30 to 60 depending
on the prevalence i mean depending on
the assay and at a one percent
prevalence level
so this got us thinking how can we
make this better
so what we decided to do was look at the
discordant specimens across each
platform
and these are discordant samples in this
case there's patients these are
pcr-positive patients positive for
startups cob2 labeled three through well
uh ranging from three to fifty-seven
however
uh right below it there's four other
patients uh these are patients
who had their plasma drawn plasma serum
drawn in
2018 and this would be coveted naive and
we
these were uh patients where we had we
saw discordance
across each of these platforms
and while it is interesting to look at
the positive the differences in the
positive patients the most important
thing for
when we were when you're trying to
screen a low problem population are your
false positives so we looked
at the false positives and we saw
that
this particular
uh patient
patient negative 78 from 2018
had a false positive on the roche assay
which was not a false positive on any of
these other assays
uh so we decided to look at the uh the
effect of doing a screen and confirm
approach which would mean that usually
basically using orthogonal assays or in
this case different assays
to
help confirm initially screen positive
um
kobe 2 serology results
so
in this case if we're using a screen and
confirm
approach
we actually see really great
positive predictive value
when you use the roche
total ig assay
and confirm with either the digest or
avid assay as you can see here
in this case because in our particular
cohort we had a
an
npa or a specificity of 100 we had no
false positives
with
the roche and the diazine combined or
the roche and the habit combined
we actually get a hundred percent uh
positive predictive value
and
this is because we the the single false
positive we observe on the roche would
uh in in this particular cohort would
have been ruled out as a false positive
and therefore we would not have reported
that out as a positive result however
the diaz i'm an avid igg assay
they
share a lot of
well more false positives and uh
they're not exclusive they share false
positives and what happens there
is
you don't see the increase in positive
predictive value that you you see
when you're combining the roche with the
diazyme or the rush of the atom and that
is important so it is
important to understand
are the false positives shared between
each assay and if there are then even
though you're using
uh different assets doesn't necessarily
mean you're getting the increase in
specificity that you're looking to get
so
at the time the cdc was also working on
this as we all know and they in fact
came up with some guidelines and at the
time
they put out this bulletin
and
they determined there was no advantage
for using igg igm or
an ig igg igm or a total antibody assay
and
they also came with a guideline to not
test low
prevalence population
and in fact to use an orthogonal testing
algorithm when testing populations with
low disease prevalence which is exactly
the conclusion that we came to in our
study
so with that said we actually went live
back in
april i believe
or sorry it's not april september
that april was for when we went live
with the diazino by itself september
this is when we went live with our
screen and confirm approach
um
so in this case
we would confir we would screen for
positives on the covas
and we would confirm positives on the
diazyme
uh
and in this case live testing became uh
began september 1st 2020 and we had our
reporting stream set out as such either
positive negative or indeterminate and
so the workflow was such as
if a
patient was screened positive on the
roche they would go to the diazyme and
if the diazyme said they were negative
we would report that as indeterminate
and if they
uh screened negative then uh these
samples these specimens wouldn't get
confirmed on the diazyme they would just
be reported as negative
so
our next question was
do antibody results mean anything
and
this was a huge question at the time
because what do these serology tests
mean
so we partnered with uh
some scientists at the scripps research
institute
and who had some
experience
with neutralizing antibody assays and so
what are neutralizing antibodies
neutralizing antibodies
are
antibodies released from your b cells
and their their job is to neutralize
an antigen and in this case the idea
would be neutralizing the spike protein
which is known to be the main
uh
method for how stars kobe's kobe 2
infects
humans
and in this case
if this spike protein which is labeled
by
in this case would be this red uh
little spikes coming out of this red
virus
uh the antibodies would bind bind
spike protein and prevent
viral entry into cells
so
our collaborators developed the
pseudovirus assay where they had
the
cyroscopy ii spike protein or s protein
on the outside of a pseudovirus
containing luciferase
and
had cells expressing the human ace2
receptor which is known to be the
the mode of entry for stars cov2
and inside those cells there's blue um
there's uh more i think it's luciferin
and
uh what happens is
if the virus gets into the cell
light is generated
however
if
uh there are neutralizing antibodies on
the uh that are able to bind
the uh
the spike protein and prevent it from
interacting with the h2 receptor viral
entry is not observed and no light is
generated so it's a life-based assay
that is measuring the ability of a
pseudovirus to either get in or not get
in because we incubated
uh
these the pseudo virus with patient
plasma containing neutralizing
antibodies
so here we have a our cohort it's a in
this case we had a positive cohort
uh containing 31 patients
uh and a negative cohort containing 100
patients the the
31
patients
uh are
pcr-positive and they had a total of 87
specimens
whereas the negative cohort had 100
specimens and uh
and mostly from individuals from 2018
but some individuals
that were
positive on a respiratory panel nucleic
acid tests for other things such as
rhinovirus other types of coronaviruses
etc or other healthy individuals from
2020 that were not infected
with stars kobe 2.
so in this case we evaluated our seas of
this pseudo-virus assay from our
collaborators we determined that the
assay is quite robust especially with
stars code v2 they also had as far as
kobe 1 ass saying
uh
these individuals infected with cysco v2
had some cross protection stars kobe 1
which is not surprising
but since we were mainly focused on star
scope 2 we moved ahead there
and in this case we have
bar graphs where we have the percentage
of samples with neutralization or
neutralizing antibodies and that was
characterized as samples with
neutralizing titers greater than 50
which which essentially means you can
dilute uh
the patient's plasma 50-fold and still
get 50 viral uh prevent 50 of the virus
from getting into the cells
so
uh we also in a similar fashion to our
previous studies we looked at the
neutralizing
neutralization titers of uh
pcr of pcr or confirmed patients our
scope we do pcr confirmed patients over
time
as you can see
uh we have one we have 13 different
patients here monitored over
up to 25 26 days and these are their
neutralization titers and they follow a
very similar trend to their antibody
levels as well so this helped us gain
some confidence that the
clinical serology assays at least seem
to
mirror or are correlated at least you
know in this small cohort
to uh
the neutralizing antibodies that are uh
that we're we we so desperately want to
be prevent severe disease and infection
so
moving forward we decided to do a
retrospective evaluation of
steropositive individual screening at
ucsd health
so
this was a huge study where we
retrospectively looked at the uh
effectively nine thousand five hundred
and thirty stars kobe two serologies
tests
and we took we focus on the the serial
positive individuals because we wanted
to see
one are these true positives we knew
that based on the math we expect about
50 percent of our igg seropositive
individual individuals
to be false positives
we wanted to see if that was actually
true
and so we did this by
uh
looking at what these 164 igg seropos
individuals would uh how they would end
up
what would their results be on the
russian avid serology platforms
so
this really helped us confirm that
there was a real benefit to screen and
confirm
approach so as you can see here we have
a graph showing on the y-axis the
positive present agreement with stars
kobe 2 neutralization
and we evaluated this for
the 164 initially
uh confirm several positive
individuals on the diazyme assay and
following a screen and confirm approach
uh with either the roche total ig assay
or the rabbit igg assay we were left
with a 96 positive or 93 uh serial
positive individuals
and
as you can see the positive percent
percent agreement with stars kobe
neutralization went up from
uh 50
which matches our one percent prevalence
level that we assumed at
uh to nearly 80 so this really does
underline the benefits of a screen and
confirm approach
so
here we also have just for a
visual for illustration we have the
values observed for samples with
with and without neutralizing antibodies
in our in all of these samples
and as you can see
in this case the diazyme assay really
performed well and with its specificity
as in
uh
[Music]
if a sample didn't have neutralization
activity uh the diazyme assay more or
less
didn't
uh
didn't have that much of a
response
however the roche and the abbot
there's a little bit more spread out um
the response was a little bit more
varied as in
there were samples that were uh negative
for neutralizing antibodies but
had very high levels and that could be
totally
uh correct uh maybe that individual
was had antibodies against stars copy 2
but they just weren't neutralizing in
nature
and same with the abbott
and
we
helped visualize this by looking at the
median levels of the positive uh
of the patients who had samples that
were positive
for neutralizing antibodies and look at
the median
uh on each of these assays and what we
see is that if we use the median as a
cutoff
for each of these specific assays we
actually have really high specificity
for the diazine assay compared to the
roche and the avid
so
one of our last questions was can we
distinguish vaccination from natural
infection
so
what we did
was we looked at two of our tried and
trued
uh
assays the diazyme igg and roche and
assay which at the time we previously we
called that the total assay but that
total assay is only against the
nucleocapsid protein
but
during this the the start of this study
diazim and roche came out with new
assays dizziness came out with a
functional neutralizing assay called the
diazyme neutralizing antibodies assay
and the roche came out with the roche s
assay which is a total antibody assay
that is directed against the spike
protein
so
here we have
four different sets of block box plots
and
in this case we looked at patients that
were stratified according to when
they received a positive sars cobia do
pcr result
as you can see
very very similar values we see
in among all the assays and the response
and
the longer the as disease progresses
these values become higher
so
we also did our own individual
clinical evaluations of the diazyme
neutralizing antibody assay and the rosh
s assay however due to time i won't be
showing that data too much
so
we did compare these assays and looking
at
the positive percent agreement to
a
individual receiving a vaccine
uh we see that we have good positive
percent agreement
uh with all the assays besides
sorry with with the both of the new
assays but not the
roche n and the diazyme igg
now we were really surprised on the
diazyme igg assay because initially we
at least from the manufacturer we were
told this was an nns assay however this
this data really suggests it's more of a
nucleocapsid assay versus a spike
protein assay as well
the roche n assay we don't actually
expect it to pick up any of vaccinated
individuals because vaccinated
individuals are
only exposed to the spike protein that
is what
either the mrna vaccines are expressing
or the adenovirus-based vaccines are
expressing or even the attenuated
viruses
and
in this case
the
the roche s and the diazine neutralizing
assays those do pick up vaccinated
individuals and that makes sense the
roche s assays developed against the
spike assay
so we expect that to pick it up
and the diazine neutralizing assay is a
functional neutralizing assay which is
looking at the ability of patient plasma
to inhibit
um the interaction with the spike
protein
and the human h2 receptor
yeah so
one might ask what is this one
individual that's positive on the assay
well it turns out that individual
actually was positive for uh active uh
an active stars cov2 infection so this
person was also naturally infected
as well as vaccinated
we then looked at in a similar fashion
individuals that had already received
their booster shot so and the what i was
showing you previously were individuals
that had not received their vaccine
booster
now that we look at individuals that
have or had received their vaccine
booster
we see that we had a 100 percent
positive percent agreement with the of
the roche s assay and 94
uh agreement with the diaz neutralizing
assay
which essentially means that
these two commercial assays can pick up
vaccinated individuals fairly robustly
in this case
we then looked at the neutralizing
antibodies with our pseudovirus based
assay by uh that were produced by
vaccinated individuals
and as you can see
we have
uh in this case a table
looking at pre-booster individuals and
the neutralizing um
and their
the presence of neutralizing antibodies
in those patients or in those
individuals
and in this case we had 24 vaccinated
individuals out of those 24 21 were
positive on the neutralizing assay so we
had a ppa of 87 percent
roughly
and
here we had to look at post booster well
if people wonder does the booster make a
difference it definitely does in this
case
we're looking at the neutralizing
activity of
individuals post booster and we had 71
that had received their boosters
and
70 were positive on the pseudo virus
based neutralizing assay so
people wonder should i be taking my
booster yeah it does make a difference
we definitely see a response which i'll
be showing you a little bit more uh
we'll
be illustrated by this next slide
so in this case
we have
on the y-axis
the
log base 10 stars cov2 ib-50 titers
and on the x-axis we have the day's post
initial injection uh receiving their
first dose of vaccine
you can see individuals
and the pre-booster uh
uh that are have not received their
boosters there
are just single-dosed
they're sort of all over the map in
terms of their neutralization titers
uh some
the line where we determined that they
have neutralizing activity is was a
hundred in this case this is so this is
a log base 10 scale so that's two
and
three individuals here hadn't reformed
sufficient neutralizing activity
uh and uh
when the ones that had not received
their booster however those that had
received their booster uh
most only one individual and they had
just received their booster here this
this triangle that is at day 25
they had just received their booster
everyone else
formed very robust uh neutralizing
titers except this individual
unfortunately we weren't able to follow
that individual for an extended period
of time to make sure that they have
formed neutralizing antibodies but it we
definitely see a distinct
change in the neutralizing
antibody titers
following the booster shots
so those three uh individuals here did
not
make
neutralizing antibodies and this single
triangle did as well
so
we also decided to look at the
correlation of commercial antibody
assays with uh pseudovirus-based
assays and the neutralizing antibodies
that are detected by them
and what we found is
we really compared only the diazine and
the roche assay the s antibody assay the
diazyme neutralizing assay and the roche
antibody assay because those are the
only ones that we had that picked up
vaccinated individuals
and we found that the diazine
neutralizing assay had a really
strong correlation positive correlation
uh with sars kobe 2 id50 titers the
roche
antibody assay also correlated however
it was not quite as
robust at 0.39
so in this case we definitely prefer
the diazyme neutralizing assay
so that brings us to our summary and
conclusions
uh
so first off uh
all of these platforms uh the diazyme
roche and habit assays
can be used to detect past exposure to
stars kobe 2.
uh it's remo it's important to remember
that positive predictive values are
poorer when screening low
prevalence populations that's true of
any clinical assay not just these
serology assays
and
in order to really be able to robustly
uh perform serology testing in low
prevalence populations a screen and
confirm approach should be used this
should help your ppvs be you know
close to or even above 90 percent
and
the neutralizing assays antibodies that
were detected
are were much more approved when you're
using a screen and confirm approach in
fact about 80 of individuals determined
to be serial positive
uh
after a screen and confirm approach had
neutralizing antibodies
and
the roche s and diazon assays robustly
detect uh infected and vaccinate
individuals
which is important to know because uh
you can actually use the n
and the uh the like and nucleocapsid
specific assays or
in this case probably the diazyme igg
assay even though it's
supposedly a s assay as well
uh to differentiate differentiate
infected versus vaccinated individuals
because vaccinated individuals will only
have antibodies against the s protein
versus
naturally infected individuals will have
antibodies against the s and n and
n
proteins and
we found that the diazyme neutralizing
antibody assay correlates strongly with
psv uh pseudovirus id50 titers and
vaccinated individuals which is makes it
a
a good assay to consider if you're
trying to
get some meaning out of these tests
so again what does this all mean
there was a recently published
relatively recently published article
article
on neutralizing antibody levels and
that they are highly predictive for
immune protection from symptomatic
psoriasis to infection
and here i just listed a few of the
conclusions from that assay from that
study which is the antibody half-life is
about 60 days
and the neutralization tire is about 108
days and that
significant loss of protection from
infection
from star scoby 2
happens around 250 days
however importantly protection from
severe disease is retained
but uh which is likely due to the prob
the
the role that memory b cells and t cells
play
so with that i'd like to acknowledge uh
my colleagues at ucsd health especially
specifically
robert fitzgerald uh who is our uh
comac clinical chemistry fellowship
director as well as all these great
individuals
as well as our
uh collaborators at the scripps research
institute
as well as uh the commercial vendors
that supported us on this journey so
with that i'd like to conclude the talk
and hope that everyone
was able to learn something
thanks for your attention